c'est un des effets positifs du
confinement pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs algériens face à la
fermeture des commerces les
consommateurs se tournent vers les
plateformes d'achat la vente en ligne
était jusqu'à présent très peu développé
en algérie
mais la crise sanitaire a changé la
donne et les professionnels ont dû
s'adapter à la hausse de la demande et
celle express est un service de
livraison tous connus sont en fait était
connu sous le nom de yes fraude qui
était spécialisée dans la livraison des
repas
ensuite vers le mois d'avril 2020 nous
avons migré vers l'essai à l'express
afin de livrer tous qui coursent
ménagères est également les repas sur la
plate forme et c'est l'extrait
ci-dessous ventre nous pouvons trouver
des restaurants des pâtisseries des
fast-foods des supérettes et de
supermarchés également déboucherez des
boulangeries ont fait une multitude de
stars grâce auquel nos consommateurs
peuvent effectuer leurs achats sans pour
autant se déplacer le e-commerce offre
de nouvelles opportunités pour les
jeunes entrepreneurs qui redoute souvent
de se lancer face au manque de
réglementation et de moyens dans ce
secteur en plein essor la demande vient
de tout le pays dès que tous les
commerces étaient fermés les gens sont
naturellement retourné par la chambre
vide ce qui a fait exploser la domaine
de la livraison express et ben on
distribue maintenant 29 fouet l'arrière
on couvre pratiquement tout le nord du
pays ça m'a permis de connaître plein de
personnes bonne ou mauvaise plein de
personnes de toutes les régions
découvrir des cultures de régions
différentes
bassan le monde soit riche à ce qu'on a
quand même en algérie
le gouvernement a lancé un appel
d'offres pour mettre en place le
paiement par mobile dans le pays
de quoi développer encore ce marché où
tout reste à créer